all right big news to start with from uh
the daily wire and also um related to
the Daily wire it says the article on
the homepage right now the daily wire of
the Federalist in the state of Texas
joined on Tuesday in a lawsuit against
the US state department alleging that
the government agency funded uh
censorship technology designed to
bankrupt domestic media Outlets with
disfavored political opinions the state
department is tasked with foreign
relations and has no authority over
domestic affairs yet it took a
government office designed for
countering foreign terrorist propaganda
which is called the global engagement
Center and Unleashed it against the
Americans engaged in what it claimed was
disinformation according to the lawsuit
filed in federal court in the eastern
district of Texas uh by the new civil
liberties Alliance it was quote one of
the most audacious manipulative
secretive and uh SEC secretive and
gravest abuses of power and
infringements of First Amendment rights
by the federal government in American
history said the suit which also names
the Secretary of State Anthony blinkin
and five other officials as defendants
the lawsuit asks the judge to declare
the the state Department's attempt to
interfere with domestic speech illegal
and to permanently bar it from
developing promoting or encouraging
others to use technology to De amplify
shadowban or restrict the lawful speech
of the American Press and
Americans GC was founded in 2011 as the
center for strategic counterterrorism
Communications and task with countering
propaganda of foreign terrorists like
al- Qaeda in 2016 it was renamed but
kept the same counterterrorism Mission
Congress has made it clear that none of
the funds authorized for the entity
shall be used for purposes other than
countering foreign propaganda
nevertheless GC turned its focus on
Americans the complaint alleges using
taxpayer funds to finance the
development and promotion of censorship
organizations such as newsguard which
we've talked about on the show and the
global disinformation index which
regularly targets conservative media
Outlets such as the daily wire and the
Federalist with the stated goal of
limiting ad
Revenue now there's a lot more to this
I'm not going to read the entire thing
it's a long article from Luke rosak but
you should go to daily wire uh and and
read it
because um it's a very important very
significant uh Free Speech case I don't
think that this lawsuit from the daily
wire and the Federalists and others is
going to get a ton of press certainly
not from the corporate press for obvious
reasons but even by other conservatives
I I don't think it's going to get a lot
of attention because it's not sexy right
it's not flashy or showy um instead it
is a smart and necessary and effective
and substantive way to fight back
against the censorship regime and we
know that very often times the smart
necessary substantive effective things
are the things that don't get a lot of
attention uh they aren't appreciated as
much be that as it may this is extremely
important because this is how censorship
works in the Modern Age so for the most
part you know the government is not
coming in and saying you're not allowed
to say this right we we we haven't we
haven't had the government show up at
the Del wire offices and say uh here are
things you're not allowed to say
anymore they haven't s federal agents
into the office to raid you know our
offices and cart me and Ben and Michael
and Candice away and handcuffs like they
haven't done that yet it may come to
that point it may well come to that
point but it hasn't happened yet um I if
Joe Biden wins a second term I would not
be
surprised in fact I
would if Joe Biden wins a second term uh
and the country is run by his handlers
for a second term I would be surprised
if we didn't get to the point where they
were actually doing Federal raids of of
you know um prominent conservative media
outlets and putting people like me in
jail but that's not where we are where
we are yet you know if you're single or
if you know someone who single you've
probably seen or heard about all the
insane dating apps out there but what if
I told you there was a dating app that
actually cared about your morals and
your biblical values well now there is
with a new dating app called higher Bond
higher bond is a new Christian dating
app buil to be safer less stressful and
more Christ centered higher bond is
completely different than anything else
out there there's no addictive swiping
the focuses truly on quality over
quantity and is designed to form lasting
marriages higher bond is a Christian
company that's veteran-owned by a
husband and wife looking to change the
way Christian singles meet online you
know it's no s secret that left-wing
media and big Tech are against companies
like higher bond in fact a big tech
company uh rejected higher bond from
running ads because their website had
the word Christian our society and our
country need what higher bond is doing
and if you're single you got to check
out higher bond.com sign up before
December 31st you get three months of
higher Bond premium absolutely free
that's higher bond.com today well if you
haven't heard my wife uh surprised me
with yet another dog in my house and I'm
really excited excited about it excited
to have a new dog and I'm also excited
to give this dog rough greens as well
maybe I'll start posting videos of the
dogs uh racing the winner gets to stay
in our family and the loser has to go
that's actually a good idea we could do
that naturopathic Dr Dennis black the
founder of Ru greens is focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America before I started feeding my dog
Ruff greens I had no idea that dog food
is dead food it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green let
rough greens bring your dogs food back
to life r greens is a supplement that
contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food just sprinkle rough Greens
on their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels and so much
more we are what we eat and that goes
for dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so confident rough greens will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump start trial bag
so your dog can try it get a free jump
start trial bag delivered straight to
your door and just just a few business
days go to Ru greens.com or call 844
ru700 that's rffg greens.com mat or call
844 Ru 700 today where we are now is
it's a more underhanded
approach and the approach instead is to
conspire to label us
misinformation and to use that as a
pretense to make our content less
accessible through
algorithms um or in this case to deprive
us of AD Revenue new which in the long
term is supposed to have the effect of
shutting down our
businesses and you know that's what
makes the whole thing less sort of
dramatic less attention grabbing in
certain ways because you know it's one
thing if if we came to you and we said
the government is telling us we're not
allowed to say this
thing everyone knows that's a big deal
but it's different when we say the
government is trying to label our
content misinformation and make it less
accessible through social media
algorithms and deprive us of Revenue
indirectly like when you say that
people's eyes start to gloss over a
little
bit um but they shouldn't because it it
is effectively the same thing it's all
they know they can't come in
directly and uh and and point guns at us
and say stop saying that again maybe
eventually it'll come to
that right now they can't get away with
it and so they're not doing that and
they found other ways to do it and
they're using counterterrorism agents
and they're using all these different uh
you know agencies and programs that were
set up for other allegedly for other
purposes and they're doing it all under
the guise of quote unquote
misinformation and and who decides what
what counts as misinformation well of
course they do the the ruling regime
does the people who believe that men can
have babies and women have penises these
the ones who are deciding what is
misinformation which by the way even if
we could
trust their their uh judgment on what
qualifies as misinformation which we
can't even if we could I would still say
this is all totally
wrong because it's just not the
government's job to counter
misinformation it's not the government's
job to declare what sort of information
you should have access to as a as as an
allegedly free citizen of an allegedly
free
country but it's made all the worse by
the fact that as we know with they say
misinformation they simply mean
information that they would prefer you
not
see whatever their reasons may be for
that and 99 times out of 100 the reason
they don't want you to see it is not
because it's wrong but because in fact
it's right thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcast